WHEN WE SAT DOWN AT A RESTAURANT
HERE IN MANHATTAN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU'RE EATING.
>> I MEAN, HONESTLY, YOUR SHOW
HAS STARTED TO MAKE ME THINK
ABOUT FOOD.
AND ABOUT THAT IT IS MORE THAN
JUST FUEL, AND THAT -- I DON'T
KNOW.
I ACTUALLY WENT TO TANGIER
BECAUSE YOU HAD GONE THERE.
AND I ENJOYED YOUR SHOW ON IT.
AND I THOUGHT YEAH, THAT WOULD
BE A COOL PLACE TO GO.
SO YOU HAVE HAD A BIG IMPACT ON
ME.
>> WELL, I'VE DONE SOME GOOD IN
THE WORLD.
WE'RE EATING WELL, NICE CHOICE.
>> YOU WENT TO PUNJAB, AND
YOU'RE EATING MORE VEGETABLES,
YOU DON'T SEEM TO HAVE A HISTORY
WITH IT.
>> YOU KNOW, INDIA, THAT IS A
PLACE I CAN EAT VEGETARIAN FOR A
LONG TIME.
AND HAPPILY.
THE FOOD IS SO WELL PREPARED.
IT IS SPICY, DELICIOUS.
INDIAN CULTURE IS VERY OLD AND
RICH.
>> YOU'RE EATING HONEST STUFF
LIKE ON THE STREET, LIKE STALLS,
LIKE GOING TO A SIKH FESTIVAL.
FOR ME, A LARGE PART OF GOING TO
INDIA IS NOT WANTING TO GET
SICK.
>> THE HYGIENE MAY NOT BE WHAT
YOU LIKE.
YES, THERE IS THE POSSIBILITY
YOU MAY SPEND A LITTLE EXTRA
TIME ON THE THUNDER BUCKET.
BUT YES, IT WON'T KILL YOU.
MY LONG EXPERIENCE ON THE ROAD,
YOU CAN EAT AT THE HOTEL BUFFET.
IT IS THE KILLER, IF ONE OF MY
CREW GOES DOWN, IT IS THAT
BUFFET.
THE SPAGHETTI BOLOGNESE.
>> THAT IS MY SAFE FOOD.
LITERALLY, WE WERE ARE IN
UKRAINE, AND I INSISTED THAT MY
CREW HAD SPAGHETTI BOLOGNESE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD
DO AFTER WORK?
I FEEL LIKE WE SHOULD GO OUT FOR
SOME NICE BOLOGNESE, AND AT THE
HOTEL AS YOU PUT THE THREE-DAY
OLD BOLOGNESE MIX AT THE HEATING
TABLE TO SLOWLY FOAM UP, UNLIKE
THE STREET STALL WHERE THEY
THINK THEY WILL SEE YOU IN THE
NEXT FEW DAYS.
YOU EAT THAT, YOU'RE SLAMMING
SHUT LIKE A BOOK ON THE PLANE
COMING HOME.
YOU'RE SAYING I THINK IT WAS A
LITTLE OLD.
>> WOW,